hello again so from now on we'll be
focusing on the transformation of
stresses in two dimensions
as I was mentioning in the previous part
of my lecture
if you have a general three-dimensional
body like this the general
two-dimensional body like this we are no
longer considering three dimensional
bodies so this is very much 2d and we
focus our attention at a particular
point Q inside it
now if you had to choose a coordinate
axis in this fashion
then to investigate the state of stress
at the point Q so this is our point Q so
to investigate in the state of stress
the two-dimensional state of stress at
the point Q referred to this choice of
our coordinate system we would take a
little element in this fashion
would take a little element like this
centered around you on the other hand if
we were interested in considering
another coordinate system so for example
we just copy or do dimensional body here
so that's nicely done
and we considered there the same point Q
here
but this time we want to consider access
which are not the X and y-axis rather
these are our
new axis X Dash and y dash which is
somewhat tilted is known that we are
considering that the same two
dimensional body we are again
considering the same point Q it is only
the choice of the coordinate axis which
has changed now corresponding to this
new choice of coordinate axis X Dash and
y dash we choose a little element
centered around Q again but which is
also rotated relative to the previous
element the blue square element that we
had considered here on the left hand
side so the physical situation despite
remaining the same in both the cases it
is the it is the choice of the
coordinate axis which has changed and
because of this the state of stress
which will be which will be describing
or the stress components which will be
describing the state of stress at the
point given the two cases will be
different so what I mean to say is that
on the left hand side we are going to
have Sigma xx Sigma YY and tau XY 1 on
the right hand side we are going to have
Sigma X dash X dash Sigma y dash y dash
and tau X dash y dash the question which
we want to answer as the primary topic
of discussion of this chapter is that
what is the mathematical relationship
between Sigma X dash X dash and Sigma xx
Sigma YY tau XY what is the relationship
between tau x dash now white tau X dash
y dash and Sigma xx Sigma YY and tau XY
how can we find that out
so to ascertain what we are going to do
is consider a very special kind of
element which will which will help us
through a force balance to find out this
relationship so let's do that
we'll consider
we'll consider
his side like this and a side like this
but we are not going to complete the
square rather we are going to understand
that this vertical edge represents an
edge which is parallel to the y axis in
the left-hand side of the diagram and
this horizontal edge here it represents
an edge which is parallel to the x axis
on the left-hand side of the diagram to
complete this picture we are going to
draw his side
which is perpendicular to the X dash
axis or which is parallel to the y dash
axis referring to the right hand side of
the above diagram so we have our
coordinate axes if we were to
superimpose the coordinate axis from the
previous diagrams here it looks somewhat
like this we will have our X dash here
would have our y dash here and our X
would be present here and our Y would be
present here
the information which we absolutely know
is the angle between X Dash and X or
equivalently the angle between y dash
and y so we know this angle let's call
that as theta now what we want to do is
carry out a force balance along the X
dash direction first and then a force
balance in the y dash direction but
before we do that we identify the three
vertices as we identify the three
vertices as
as L m and
now what we want to do first of all is
to note that on the face LM the stress
components which will appear our Sigma
xx and tau XY so we write them down
similarly on the edge m and the stress
components which are going to appear are
Sigma YY and tau XY while on the edge Ln
the stress components that are going to
appear are
Sigma X - x - and
Dow X - why - all right for the purpose
of the force balance it will be
important to take various components not
only do we have to take the force
components associated with the various
stress components but we'll also have to
take the components of the areas which
represent the areas of these along these
edges so for example if we denote the
area along the face Ln so you understand
that in a real three-dimensional
situation this would be a face Ln going
into the plane of the paper may be of
unit width so we say that that L an edge
that is the projection of an actual area
which is going into the plane of the
paper and let us say that that area is
is depicted by the capital letter A so
the area of this edge ellen is a now if
this angle is theta so if this angle is
Theta then we know that this angle will
also be theta which means this angle
would be theta and this angle would be
90 degree minus theta so we are now in a
position to go ahead and do the force
balance along the x-direction
so Sigma F X dash is equal to zero
so what that will give us and remember
that we have to keep track of the
components of the forces which are
associated with the various stress
components properly as well as the
directions so we have to take the
component of the force which is
associated with this stress components
Sigma xx along the x direction similarly
for this tau XY for the Sigma YY and the
Tau XY so first of all considering the
edge L M we write Sigma xx first of all
the area of the face L n would be a cos
theta because you see here that this
angle is Theta this is a so L M would be
a cos theta so we can write it down here
so Ln has area here this is the area
LM is e cos theta and M end is a sine
theta
so what we are writing here is Sigma xx
LM so that is basically a COS theta now
this is the force which is acting along
the negative x-direction now we want
this force we want the component of this
force along the X - direction so far
along the X - direction so what we want
to do is take the component of this
noting that this particular force so if
you are looking at this this is making
an angle theta so you understand that
this is the line which is parallel to
the X - direction so we have to take a
cos theta here and there's there's a
minus here
there's a minus here because it is along
the negative x - x - direction next
again considering the phase LM we have
the contribution from tau XY so without
writing minus or plus for a slight write
down the contribution from tau XY the
force due to tau XY which will be also
along will be multiplied with a cos
theta because it is along LM and we have
to take the component of this force
which is acting along the negative y
direction because you see that this is
the the force will be along this
direction so this is the negative y
direction and you take the component of
this along this line again and this
angle is 90 degree minus theta so this
is a sine theta and this is again in the
negative x direction so we have a minus
here next we are going to consider the
edge M N and the first force that we are
going to consider on the edge MN is the
one associated with Sigma Y Sigma YY so
the force associated with this thing
so again before without writing any
minus a plus we consider the force the
Sigma YY multiplied with MN MN has the
area a sine theta as you can see here
now this force is acting along the minus
y direction and we have to take the
component of it parallel to X - now this
angle is again 90 degree minus theta so
this is cos of 90 degree minus theta so
that's a sine theta and because it is
acting along the negative x-direction
there should be a minus here and finally
we are going to take the force
contribution due to this tau XY so tau
XY a sine theta they this a sine theta
comes because we are considering the
edge MN and then we have to take the
component of this force along the X
direction and you note that the angle
that this force makes with the X
Direction is nothing but theta so that's
a cos theta here but this is along the
negative x direction so we need a minus
sign here and finally we should not
forget the edge L n on which the force
which is acting along the x direction is
simply Sigma X - x - multiplied with a
and we don't have to take any component
because this is entirely along the X -
direction and this is very much with a
positive sign this is equal to zero so
overall what we have and you can see
that from all the terms the the area
cancels so what we'll have eventually is
Sigma X - X Dash is equal to Sigma xx
cos square theta plus Sigma YY sine
square theta plus two tau XY sine theta
cos theta that's it
so in the next part of the lecture we
are going to address the summation of
the force along the Y - direction